how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to the channel today we
have some awesome news about the
Fantastic Four there's been a lot of
hype about the Fantastic Four going
around lately and there's even been a
ton of hype about them before is San
Diego comic-con of 2019 where of course
Kevin Feige name drops them then we got
some reports that they are going to be
coming in 2022 and since there isn't
likely going to be an Avengers team for
quite some time in the MCU during phase
four and phase five they're going to be
one of the main teams so there's
absolutely no doubt that they're going
to be coming to the MCU soon but now
thanks to a Marvel employee himself it
seems like we could be getting some
official news soon so I'll break down
this news and when we could expect to
hear it if it does in fact happen in
this video I'm still doing my xbox one
and ps4 giveaway so be sure to subscribe
when notifications turned on like the
video and comment down below so you can
enter for a chance to win so if you've
been a fan in the community for some
time now you probably know who boss
logic is he's become really really
popular because of his digital art
reaching almost two million followers on
Instagram doing some edits for Ryan
Reynolds Hugh Jackman Jake Gyllenhaal
where he was recently on The Tonight
Show with Jimmy Fallon talking about
boss logic that's actually a guy named
boss logic he did that actually yeah
yeah yeah we should be shout out to that
guy cuz I didn't I have I have no
artistic skill whatsoever there'd be no
possibility I could call that boss logic
yeah so he's really well known and he
does amazing work but he also works for
Marvel he did some official posters for
Avengers end game for them and he did
some posters for spider-man far from
home as well including doing some promos
for them too so he works for Marvel
directly and yesterday he teased that we
may be getting some info about the
Fantastic Four soon yesterday he posted
to Instagram a picture that he of course
designed himself of the Fantastic Four
logo partly on fire of course because of
the Human Torch with the word phase next
to it of course sane phase four and in
the description he said I feel like we
may get some news soon now keep in mind
this is a person that Marvel
pays to design posters and characters
for Marvel Studios directly so if there
has been any concept art designed or
talked about about the Fantastic Four
he's definitely somebody who would
probably be in the know but the
interesting thing here is that his
design is for phase four implying that
the Fantastic Four could be coming in
phase four now this has kind of been
expected and there have been reports
stating that some of the characters
could show up in phase four not their
official Fantastic Four movie debut in
phase four but cameos there's been a
report by Mikey Sutton that mr.
fantastic could show up in Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness at
the end to talk about the Illuminati and
of course they could appear in any other
film for phase four even possibly a
Disney Plus series but let's talk about
the fact that he said we may get some
news soon well Marvel Studios and Disney
have some events that aren't too far
away we have CinemaCon and then of
course we have San Diego comic-con
now cinema con is in March March 30th to
April 2nd and it's already been revealed
that Marvel Studios has booked 2 hours
and 45 minutes for their panel there and
there is a very real possibility that
Marvel Studios could talk about the
Fantastic Four there after all Kevin
Feige has already publicly announced
that they do have phase 5 done they have
the next five years done he was going to
announce it at last year San Diego
comic-con but they decided that all of
the films and phase 4 were enough and
when he left last year San Diego
comic-con panel one of his last words
were we didn't even have time to talk
about the Fantastic Four well 2 hours
and 45 minutes at CinemaCon is certainly
enough time to talk about some upcoming
projects and then not to mention we have
San Diego Comicon coming up in July and
that's really not that far away and
there is absolutely no doubt that
they're going to reveal phase 5 at San
Diego comic-con which is where we will
most likely see the official reveal of
the Fantastic Four and hopefully the
x-men so again we've had plenty of
reports saying that the Fantastic Four
are coming soon but now we have somebody
who works for Marvel directly teasing
that we will most likely be hearing some
news about the Fantastic Four very soon
so it seems like they are coming to the
MCU and it seems like it's not going to
be too long from now let me know how
excited you are for the Fantastic Four
to enter the MCU finally and if they
have to debut and cameo in a movie
before they get their own
which movie would you like that to be
let me know in the comments down below
also don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and notifications turned on so
you can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof